[Musique]
monaco avait l'air renfrogné au départ
du grand prix monte carl pas un rayon de
soleil en effet et même quelques gouttes
de pluie pour moment où les seize
kaulitz et danse dans les rues de la
cité c est ce bolide qui s'emballe les
300 chevaux qui s'emballe sous le capot
d'une voiture de course cela fait du
bruit et cela cause aussi parfois des
accidents résultat trois voitures hors
course dans celle de maurice trintignant
elles n'ont pas parcouru plus de 200 m
les autres pilotes ne s'en soucie guère
le prytanée g il mène la rente suivi du
néo zélandais mc laren et de l'américain
filer et pendant 92 tours sur les
ceintures que comportent les preuves
graham hill avec la virtuosité
tranquille des pilotes sûr de son
affaire continue de tourner seul en tête
à plus de 110 de moyenne
grâce à 25 kilomètres du but sa boîte de
vitesses a rendu l'âme et c'est la
numéro 14 de matelas rhin l'atlantiste
qui va franchir en tête la ligne
d'arrivée aspirant dans son sillage la
ferrari de ville ive
[Applaudissements]
fini les chevaux de bois de nos
grands-mères en californie la classe
biberon préfère les émotions fortes
chaque année il en est ainsi dans la
petite ville de san inox
en pratique le rodéo comme des grands
parfois avec la maîtrise des vrais cow
boys comme dans les westerns
des bûches il y en aura pour tout le
monde
et non se réjouir du malheur des autres
cet âge est décidément sans pitié le
taureau également et en californie on
est pour l'égalité des sexes les filles
en piste comme les gars c'est évidemment
moins paisible qu'un concours de beauté
le château de champs a prêté son cadre
au quatrième week-end franco-britannique
qui grâce au premier soleil de juin ne
s'est pas cantonnée au coin du feu
cordiales et franches tel fut
l'atmosphère dans laquelle le général de
gaulle et monsieur macmillan ont étudié
le problème numéro un la participation
de l'angleterre à l'europe des six
[Musique]
triomphateur du cosmos scott carpenter
frais et dispos comme au départ à
retrouver à son retour de l'île du grand
turc sa femme sa mère et ses quatre
enfants avec une joie attendre que
laisse bien deviné ces images personne
bien sûr n'avait suivi son voyage avec
autant de ferveur autant d'impatience et
bien entendu tout le monde est allé
regarder la capsule à l'intérieur de
laquelle ce grand garçon avait passé
près de cinq heures pendant ces trois
tours de terre à manipuler les manettes
et les boutons de son mystérieux tableau
de bord de cet immense succès de cette
grande aventure voici le témoin absolue
cette petite cage et wat qui est allé
frôler les astres
[Musique]
à jérusalem adolf eichmann condamné à
mort pour l'extermination de six
millions de juifs a pris place une
nouvelle fois dans la cage de verre du
palais de justice de jérusalem la
dernière c'était en effet pour entendre
prononcé le rejet de son appel par le
juge s'il berg au nom de la cour suprême
israélienne
où
rien ne sauverait plus ashman désormais
deux jours plus tard la grâce lui était
refusée et la peine immédiatement
appliquées c'était pour la potence cas
eichmann quitté sa cage de verre le
pourrons a payé
si l'on peut jamais payé pour pareil
crime
[Musique]
et les bris calcinés c'est tout ce qui
reste du boeing 707 qui devait ramener
de paris atlanta 123 touristes
américains avec huit membres de
l'équipage ont péri seul rescapé deux
hôtesses éjecté de la carlingue ont
miraculeusement survécu
n'ayant pu décoller le mastodonte est
venu s'écraser après une course folle de
300 mètres au delà de la piste d'orly
entre deux pavillons de villeneuve le
roi et c'est une chance qu'on n'ait pas
aujourd'hui à déplorer d'autres victimes
parmi les habitants une des plus grandes
catastrophes aériennes
[Musique]
le camp de valdahon près de besançon
trois mille officiers parmi lesquels des
officiers allemands ont découvert les
grandes manoeuvres de l'armée futur
c'est exceptionnel manoeuvre interarmes
faux et usage en effet des derniers
modèles de matériel et en particulier
des chars équipés d'engins téléguidé de
conception française un épisode de la
guerre presse bouton
si buffon a pu dire un jour le cheval la
plus noble conquête de l'homme c'est que
cette affirmation s'étaient traduites
dans la réalité des les âges les plus
reculées le cheval fut en effet de tout
temps et les à l'idée de combat de
victoire de succès
et dans un domaine plus terre-à-terre
l'enfant at il jamais réclamé plus
ardemment un autre compagnon qu'un
cheval
de là le succès à travers les
générations des chevaux de bois de nos
jardins publics et d orchestrer ion dont
le tournoiement régulier a bercé toutes
les enfances
de là aussi le succès des chevaux à
jupon commun à nombre de traditions
folkloriques de nos provinces
et là nous n'a pas cesser de perpétrer
ces jeux de chevaux porteurs de chance
c'est peut-être de cette mystique cheval
égale chance que s'inspire cette année
le grand prix de paris or de l'attrait
qu'elles apportent aux turfistes cette
course déterminera en effet au
sweepstake de la loterie nationale
l'affectation des plus gros lot 100
millions 200 millions et encore plus de
30 noms de saints à 50 millions de quoi
rêver
[Musique]
en ce mois de mai dans le décor
renaissance de la cour du belvédère au
vatican on pourrait presque se croire
revenu au xvième siècle dans le costume
que dessina pour eux michel-ange les
nouvelles recrues de la garde suisse ont
prêté serment comme elles l'ont fait
depuis la création de leur corps voici
plus de quatre siècles et demi
[Musique]
non
la main gauche sur la rampe du drapeau
les trois doigts de la main droite levée
en signe de dévotion à la sainte trinité
chaque nouvelle enrôler a juré fidélité
au souverain pontife
rien n'a changé depuis jules 2 mais
alors la garde suisse comptait 200
hommes elle n'en compte plus que la
moitié depuis le pape léon xiii
[Musique]
à
on
du balcon sa sainteté jean xxiii a salué
comme ses prédécesseurs ces soldats d'un
autre âge dont la présence dans leurs
aspects inchangé perpétue une tradition
et exalte un souvenir le souvenir des
147 gardes suisses qui tombèrent dans 15
127 en défendant la ville éternelle
contre les north que naît du connétable
de bourbon
[Musique]
la cadence des retour d'algérie s'est
accrue cette semaine en même temps que
le paquebot el djazaïr tout est pourtant
accosté le quesnoy en porteur d'un
nouveau milliers de radios
c'est presque 8000 retours quotidiens a
annoncé deux secrétaires d'état ont
rapatrié monsieur poulat que nous des
comptes ont maintenant femmes et enfants
forment la majorité de ces retours qui
en général après un passage au centre
d'accueil se disperse pour retrouver un
toit dans leur famille ou chez des amis
métropolitains en attendant que l'avenir
leur désigne leur chemin établissements
en france nous rentrer en algérie où il
retrouve en un pays qu'ils aiment ou ils
ont en fait déjà
[Musique]
la proche du référendum
d'autodétermination en dépit des
nouveaux drames déchaînée par loi s
après dix jours de trêve à déterminer
certaines mesures messali hadj leader du
mnr a été rendu à une complète liberté
son parti prendra part à la campagne du
référendum comme le fln et certains
partis politiques
et dans un discours-programme le général
de gaulle a mis les français en présence
à la fois des frais et de ses grandes
espérances bas 23 vous
pour la france le problème algérien
sera résolu au fort
l'algérie disposera des mêmes
l'algérie et la france
pour coopérer organiquement et
régulièrement dès lors
que
rufin il doit rejouer demain en algérie
les français qui sont établies
qu il aime
qui ont tant fait déjà
et dans ce pays a pas besoin
une fois de plus
j'affirme bon espoir
que ce revu le jour entraînements
dès que sera dissipé
les derniers nuages sans dents
par lesquels des fous criminels tentent
encore de les égarer
le général de gaulle ensuite évoqué la
question des institutions dans 9 hrs
accompli et dans l'avenir français ce
qu'il fallait faire
fut fait
mais c'est chacun la bulle parce que
les institutions nouvelles permettent
talitha bazire au lieu que les anciennes
ne pouvait que l'on a pêché
françaises français
shaka a vu
que la fidl confiance dont vous m'avez
en masse
investi
ma moi même obligé et soutenu
jour après jour
et
que cet accord vient entre le peuple
et celui qui a la charge de le conduire
est devenu dans les temps modernes est
essentielle à la république
le salon international de l'aviation
légère à cannes présente cette année des
avions pour tous les goûts et pour
toutes les bourses
à l'occasion de ce salon s'est déroulée
une journée militaire de l'aviation est
ici on peut apprécier la maniabilité du
nord 3202 dans un très joli vol de
groupe
l'ico pts rc le saint bernard du xxème
siècle ici une opération de sauvetage
mais l'hélicoptère c'est aussi la bonne
à tout faire c'est peut-être cela la
dépanneuse de demain pour les
automobilistes ça évitera en tout cas
les embouteillages
dans ce genre d'opération avec
l'hélicoptère jean en risque d'attraper
le tournis il est plus prudent de se
poser ensuite sur la plate forme d'un
camion pour retrouver ses esprits
alouette iii mérite bien son nom elle
évolue tout aussi facilement qu'un petit
oiseau et comme les petits oiseaux
n'aime pas voler seul ils s'organisent
entre eux un petit balai mais là il
s'agit d' alouettes 2
pour les dizaines de milliers de
britanniques qui assistent au derby
d'epsom c'est un jour de fête et comme
on est entre soi on n'hésite pas à
afficher un peu de laisser-aller
le côté col dur c'est pour la tribune
officielle la reine n'est pas là elle
est enrhumé mais la reine mère la
princesse margaret et tony n'ont pas
voulu manquer là
il ya 26 chevaux départ 26 chevaux qui
vont offrir le plus extraordinaire
spectacle qu'on ait vu à epsom depuis
j'avais bien raison de chercher vos
favoris à la jumelle ils ne vont pas
rester longtemps dans le peloton le
derby d'epsom va battre cette année les
records de chutes du grand ce type de
liverpool et pourtant à epsom il n'y a
pas l'ombre d'un obstacle un faux-pas de
romulus l'un des concurrents et c'est la
chute en cascade
bilan sept chevaux les quatre fers en
l'air l'un d'entre eux doit d'être
abattus et si jockey à l'hôpital
il est maintenant plus sage de rentrer à
l'écurie et pendant ce temps les
rescapés fonce vers le poteau il en
reste encore suffisamment pour rendre la
fin de course attrayant une fin de
course catastrophique pour l'élevage
anglais dans les trois premiers un
cheval irlandais et du chevaux français
et c'est l'irlandais l'ars perd qui
gagne devant marc corps et le cantilien
cette petite promenade de 2400 mètres
rapporte 50 millions aux propriétaires
du fal et 5 millions au jockey
[Applaudissements]
oui
parle de vacances on y arrive dans un
mois nous allons retrouver ce spectacle
insolite d'une ville vidée de ses
habitants comme par un coup de pompe car
chose étonnante du 15 juillet au 1er
septembre tout le monde semble avoir mis
la clé sous la porte c'est le moment où
la plupart des usines se précipite dans
le même soleil et ce congé massif jette
aux mêmes dates sur les gares et sur les
routes des millions d'êtres qui veulent
se croire en vacances
délicieuse vacances de trains bourret et
de routes encombrées mais bien sûr on a
le droit d'aimer ça
là dessus on va se retrouver en full les
mêmes foules dans les endroits
touristiques
on va jouer les sardines sur les plages
enfin seuls à nous distille les horizons
solitaire la quiétude des petits coins
tranquilles à nous le silence de la mer
à nous aussi le confort du séjour à
l'éloquence de ces signes qui semble
vous dira tout de même si vous étiez
venu plus tôt plus tard en juin ou en
septembre
[Musique]
ah
non c'est aussi un sport estival de
coucher à la dure
mais pas grave et que la cause soit doux
comme vous le dit
connais toi toi même recommandé socrates
on peut évidemment allé interroger son
visage dans les glaces du musée grévin
on peut aussi procéder plus
scientifiquement reconstitué par exemple
le visage en n'utilisant que le côté
droit ou en n'utilisant que le côté
gauche
c'est le procédé d amy face qui fait
rage actuellement photographie le cinéma
lui peut réaliser l'opération en direct
si l'on peut dire sans l'aide d'une
paire de ciseaux le système d'optique de
dufour et leclerc en effet placé devant
l'appareil de prise de vue permet à
l'aide d'un miroir réglable d'isoler
chaque côté d'un visage et de montrer
chaque demi visage en un visage complet
ainsi verra-t-on apparaître derrière
elle tous les jours la personnalité
saturnienne que révèle le côté gauche et
la personnalité et ne viennent que
cachait le côté droit du visage bien
entendu on peut aussi faire un seul le
audelin avec le bas de l'autre mais ceci
n'est qu'une fantaisie
autrement plus instructives et fernand
raynaud a bien voulu se prêter à cette
opération à discrète et la découverte
des deux aspects secrets d'un même
visage les spécialistes sont formels les
deux métamorphoses successives net
annulé deux personnalités contradictoire
que chacun ne cache en lui
[Musique]
de raymond devos voici révélé grâce à
l'hémisphère gauche un mois social
disons épanouie
quant à sacha distel lenny face droite
révèle un moins intimes qu'on pourra
juger timide au regard d'un mois sociale
affirmée et il faudra mettre que jean
richard somme toute cache bien son moi
intime
social à vous de jouer maintenant
[Musique]
combien demain le général de gaulle
at-il serré dans la foule qui tout au
long de son voyage en franche-comté l'a
acclamé avec chaleur en effet à dole à
lons le saunier partout s'arrêta le
cortège présidentiel une foule compacte
se pressait autour du général pour le
voir et l'écouter
poussé au cours de ce voyage un projet
d'attentât devait être découverts et
leurs promoteurs arrêter cet incident ne
changea rien au déroulement des
cérémonies à l'horaire du voyage et
n'enthousiasme général non manifesta que
plus d'ampleur
dans ses nombreuses allocutions le
général de gaulle a évoqué les épreuves
surmontées et dont la plus récente est
le drame algérien mais il a surtout
parlé de l'europe de donald cette europe
qui doit être l'europe des peuples c'est
à dire celle des états et non pas celle
des mots des mythes et des combinaisons
tous les jours entre berlin est et
berlin ouest des messages s'échange
messages lumineux que la lumière du jour
en plus discret aussi le gouvernement de
bangkok sans doute la satisfait de la
barrière qui l'adresser s'est mis en
devoir de renforcer et d'étendre ce
barrage constamment surveillé que les
allemands de l'ouest nomme le mur de la
honte
les nouveaux travaux comporteront des
barbelés 10 m de terres labourées 30 m
de terrains nus des barbelés un champ de
mines de 25 des barbelés 130 m de
terrain où toute végétation et toute
construction auront été supprimés une
zone de cinq km où l'on ne pourra
accéder qu'avec un sauf-conduit spécial
l'image d'un immense camp de
concentration
la sphère laotienne est elle enfin réglé
le prince bonhomme est venu dans la
plaine des jarres donné son accord à la
constitution d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale auquel d'ailleurs il ne
participera pas
le prince où va nous vendre lui chef du
pathet lao d'obédience communiste sera
ministre de l'économie et du plan le
général phung me pro occidental sera
ministre des finances quant au rôle de
premier ministre il sera assumé par le
prince neutraliste souvent à foum a
chargé également de la défense nationale
de l'action sociale et des anciens
combattants après cinquante crise les
princes là aussi un sont enfin d'accord
la satisfaction est semble-t-il général
dans le monde
hong kong n'a pas résolu ses problèmes
il s'en faut la ville surpeuplée
incapables de loger tous ces immigrants
elle compte actuellement trois millions
et demi d'habitants se trouve maintenant
devant le problème de l'eau hong kong a
soif une sécheresse exceptionnelle à
vider les torrents où ne coule plus
qu'un mince filet d'eau
bien sûr on construit un nouveau
réservoir mais les travaux sont encore
loin d'être achevé et le pipeline qui le
reliera la ville n'est pas installé
pour l'heure le saut est roi et la
corvée d'eau occupe l'essentiel des
activités des femmes des enfants hong
kong se débattait déjà avec le problème
du logement de la nourriture et du
travail d'une population pléthorique 116
grossi par les réfugiés chinois le
manque d'eau vient encore de compliquer
dramatiquement la situation
[Musique]
salahi on l'a attendu longtemps mais il
ya cette année du nouveau sous le soleil
un style tout neuf le style petits
matelots appris le français va dedans
allons largement évasée tricot rayé
volontiers barré d'un ceinturon qui fait
la taille basse la nouvelle vague n'aura
pas que le pied marin les robes elles
sont rares ce portefeuille est à la
matelote mais on leur préfère les
pantalons et les mariniers et le
clipping et toujours aubert
les plages vont donc ainsi voir fleurir
toute une armée de petits marins joly il
faut le dire a troqué
[Musique]
en attendant les bords de mer la
nouvelle mode s'est affirmée sur les
bords de marne ce qui a permis de
constater que les maillots de bain avait
aussi résolument évolué
[Musique]
des deux pièces mais le soutien gorge
peut devenir brassière et le slip
culotte
[Musique]
les maillots une pièce on leur devant -
dégager le décolleté se portent
véritablement dans le dos avec alors la
plus grande générosité mais avec
l'addition d'un noeud pour les plus
collet monté grande veuves aussi des
maillots asymétrique il reste qu'il y
aura toujours bien entendu des
réactionnaires
[Musique]
ces nouveaux modèles ne sont pas
allergiques à l'eau
l'hôtel de ville après l'hôpital
mustapha
l'offensive de destruction avait marqué
une nette recrudescence à alger et
l'explosion de 50 kg de plastique dans
la maison communale avait fait un mort
et 43 blessés parmi les waf qui était
quand année
[Musique]
mais cette dévastation spectaculaire or
at elle marqué la fin de l'opération
terre brûlée le 17 juin qui vit la
conclusion des accords fnl wes aura-t-il
marqué en algérie la fin du drame on
veut le croire et ils voudront sans
aucun doute le croire ce que deux jours
plus tôt la peur avait jeté vers le port
d'alger la peur peur du meurtre d'or
d'un enlèvement peur d'une balle perdue
peur de tout
ils étaient ce jour-là 15 cents ou 2000
femmes enfants vieillards qui s'embarque
est pour la métropole sur l'un des
bateaux qui font sans interruption la
navette à travers la méditerranée
92000 rapatriés en 12 j'ouvre tel avait
été le record des départs depuis le
discours de monsieur benbada à tunis en
25 heures de traversée sur le pont du
navire ils ont essayé d'oublier le
cauchemar dans lequel il vivait et
beaucoup pensaient que sans doute il
était parti pour ne plus revenir
[Musique]
ils sont arrivés soulager peut être mais
surtout désorienté genre de condition
modeste vieillard qui avait vécu en
algérie toute leur vie ils ont tout
laissé de l'autre côté de la mer à cela
la corde rocher noir apporte-t-il la
promesse d'un apaisement d'une
possibilité de retour
la promesse que les enfants accueillis à
la pouponnière n'auront pas commencer à
marseille une vie de déracinés et pour
tous en france comme en algérie l'heure
qui vient de sonner est-elle le signe de
la réconciliation
de l'espoir retrouvé
depuis l'accord de rochers noirs alger
sinon toute l'algérie a retrouvé le
calme peu à peu la rue avec le retour
progressif des musulmans dans les
quartiers européens a repris son aspect
d'autrefois
le photographe de la rue à réinstaller
son inventaire
les deux communautés timidement d'abord
on commençait à réapprendre à vivre
ensemble
pour la population musulmane à huit
jours du scrutin d'autodétermination
la campagne du référendum est du reste
la grande affaire sur les murs sur la
chaussée le mot indépendance s'est
multiplié
pendant ce temps dans l'algérois le fln
a poursuivi ses réunions
[Musique]
à larbaâ 50 km d'alger au milieu de
vingt mille personnes si mokhtar le chef
de la wilaya iv a pris la parole des
slogans tous aux urnes mais aussi pour
les européens vivent la main dans la
main
à paris le général de gaulle accueillait
le 12e des présidents des républiques
noir d'expression française en visite
officielle en france monsieur david
dacko président de la république
centrafricaine
un dîner de gala de démarquer à l'elysée
la visite de trois jours benjamin des
chefs d'état africains monsieur d'akon
en effet que 32 ans il rapportera dans
sa lointaine patrie le souvenir d'une
france après avoir été tout élève reste
profondément amical
[Musique]
à
la gare de metz le premier ministre
monsieur georges pompidou est allé
recueillir le chancelier fédéral
d'autriche monsieur ghorbal d'une
question au centre du séjour à paris de
l'homme d'état autrichien la possibilité
pour l'autriche pays neutre d'une
association au marché commun
non
evian a été le rendez vous des
professionnels de la presse la biennale
internationale de l'information célébrer
le dixième anniversaire de sa création
au cours de cette manifestation le
secrétaire d'état à l'information
monsieur alain peyrefitte a remis la
coupe d'or à monsieur claude valeur
parce qu'elles ont toujours été
considérés comme les ambassadrices de
charme et de l'élégance française il
était naturel que les hôtesses de l'air
fussent conviés en voisine à
l'inauguration de la nouvelle usine de
la beauté qui viennent s'ouvrir à
chevilly-larue la beauté on le sait est
en france l'un des premiers articles
d'exportation et la parfumerie figure
dans le peloton de tête des industries
exportatrices les deux tiers de sa
production partout pour l'étranger
situé au près de ce carrefour du monde
qui et orly le nouveau complexe
industriel verra ses produits s'envoler
vers 129 pays où ils sont distribués
dans 10000 points de vente quand on
parle de l'élégance de paris on pense
d'abord à la haute couture la parfumerie
avec ces modernes usine où la beauté se
prépare aujourd'hui à l'échelle
industrielle en est l'une des
propagatrice les plus puissantes
[Musique]
chaque année c'est la même chose à
diemeringen en hollande on à la
troublante sensation de voir d'où
précisons tout de suite qu'il convient
de l'incriminer aucun abus liquide dans
cette affaire ni moyenne et simplement
le lieu de rendez-vous annuel des jeunes
300 jumeaux autrement dit 150 paires de
congressistes de tous âges se sont
retrouvés cette année
on
que dire de ce progrès sinon qu'il
favorise évidemment les dédoublements
par la formation de couples parfaitement
identiques reste que pour être semblable
les jumeaux n'en n'ont pas moins des
tempéraments différents on le vit bien
cette fois lorsqu'il s'est agi de danser
le twist
ces sommes ne sont sans doute pas des
ingrats puisqu'ils n'étaient plus de
60000 à longchamp grand prix de paris
pour admirer leurs plus noble conquête
ce n'est pas celle que vous croyez on a
certes beaucoup regardé ces jolis
chapeaux mais c'est pour les chevaux
qu'on a réservé son enthousiasme sous
les sabots de l'un de ses chevaux la
fortune sur les 3000 mètres du parcours
il ya là de quoi rendre cardiaque des
milliers de parieurs de fait après
quelques foulées la moitié des
spectateurs de longchamp a déjà des
palpitations val de loire le grand
favori est triste il n'a pas envie de
courir il est bon dernier
dans la dernière ligne droite il essaie
de se rappeler qu'il est le meilleur
cheval du lot il est alors un peu tard
pour retrouver la joie de courir et
c'est armistice un brave cheval qui
personne ne pensait qu'il file vers
l'arrivée c'est un miracle il est mené
par un jockey boîte urgent de forges qui
le dirige vers la victoire de faure j'en
ai fait il n'y a pas si longtemps était
cloué sur un lit d'hôpital après un
terrible accident
c'est sur cet équipage bien sympathique
plus à bas la pluie d'or réservé au
vainqueur du grand prix
lors de l'apothéose par dizaines de
milliers les brésiliens le président
foulard en tête sont venues accueillir
le champion du monde de football à
l'aérodrome de brasilia le brésil en a
oublié tous ces soucis et tout son
enthousiasme comme à l'heure du carnaval
c'est à ces champions qui le réserve
pour les peler les santos lady di cette
ultime épreuve est plus redoutable que
la finale de la coupe du monde ils sont
tout de même un tract lorsqu'il arrive
au palais présidentiel
cette petite voiture qui est attendu
l'été pour éclore c'est le dernier
modèle de la régie renault la r8 elle
est tout à fait différente de sa grande
soeur la dauphine elle est plus
spacieuse et aussi plus confortable
c'est la première voiture de grande
série dans le monde qu'ils soient munis
de quatre freins à disques autre
avantage pour le conducteur est ourdi
avec son moteur sierra la r8 n'a pas
besoin d'eau en été pas plus que
d'antigel pour les grands froids et si
le coeur vous en dit vous avez le choix
24 heures du mans se prépare d'abord
dans la coulisse au paradis des
mécaniciens une nécessité absolue pour
préparer la victoire le réglage des
phares et la vérification de l'allumage
sur la part cédé reposent les chances
françaises ne pas oublier non plus que
le moteur ça déborde lui et boissy
l'envers du décor ici ceux qui ne se
doute de rien ceux qui sont là pour
s'étourdir en regardant passer les
bolides sans se rendre compte de
l'effort qu'il a fallu pour mettre les
voitures au point ces voitures elles
sont 55 vont essayer de tenir pendant 24
heures en roulant à tombeau
et c'est le ballet des voitures qui
cherchent à se faufiler pour s'assurer
dès le début la meilleure place
pendant ce temps c'est un autre ballet
celui de la kermesse là c'est le circuit
les spectateurs où l'on consomme autant
de liquide qu'une ferrari
les beaux châssis il n'y en a pas
seulement sur la piste
mais sur la piste on laisse à peine le
temps au spectateur de pouvoir c'est à
près de 300 à l'heure que des bolides
pons dans les lignes droites en
attendant la nuit c'est un chassé-croisé
perpétuel entre les paires harry les
aston martin et les maserati des
monstres qui développe près de 4 200
jeux
en petites cylindrées une voiture
française domine l'eau si la part cds
dérivés de la pl 17 de monsieur tout le
monde elle tourne avec régularité 101 à
coup en orbite des grosses bottines
et quand la nuit se termine il ne reste
plus beaucoup de voitures en cours sur
55 il n'y en aura que 18 à l'arrivée
tour à tour les aston martin les
maserati ont cédé le pas à la ferrari
numéro 6 de file et gendebien la
victoire finale revient à la ferrari
mais la petite poire cd pilotée par
guillaume à hébertot prend la première
place à l'indicé de performance
si la 10e victoire de pas un roman
[Musique]